[Music]
on this Sunday night Hospital of
Horrors dozens of premature babies are
rescued from gaza's main hospital as
Israel releases what it calls evidence
Hamas used the hospital as a shield
Hamas was hiding and murdering our
hostages in chifa hospital Taylor's tour
tragedy Swift cancels concerts after a
fan dies in Rio's record Heat
the gray cup kicks off with a neverbe
seen
matchup plus remembering Rosy i' like to
know what's going on jimm has always um
involved me former first lady and mental
health activist Rosalyn Carter dies at
96 global national with faren Asser
reporting tonight Jeff simple good
evening and thank you for joining us 4
days after Israeli soldiers stormed into
gaza's largest hospital a United Nations
team has been allowed in and is
describing alifa as a death zone un
Medics helped remove 31 premature babies
from the hospital more than 200 other
civilians remain stranded there some
critically ill Israel also released what
it calls unequivocal proof that alifa
was operating as a Hamas Command Center
Israel claims this video shows a Hamas
tunnel beneath the hospital and it says
this security footage from October 7th
shows Hamas bringing hostages inside
Global News has not independently
verified those claims which Hamas denies
but if true they would support Israel's
position that it needed to Target the
hospital Redmond Shannon has our top
story and a warning you may find some of
the images
upsetting the most vulnerable of all
premature babies fighting for Life their
struggle made more difficult by
War they are now in relative safety
moved south from the besieged alifa
hospital in Gaza City to the emirati
hospital in Rafa near the Egyptian
border they didn't receive any
medications and they was with
hypothermia because there were not in
incubators but in C and in the beds and
in not suitable conditions for them to
stay alive the infants are scheduled to
be transported onward to Egypt on Monday
medical staff say 31 of 39 neonatal
babies at alifa survived to make it this
far they say six of the eight who died
did so due to a lack of clean water in
gaza's largest hospital Israeli forces
entered the Gaza City complex on
Wednesday as part of their ground
offensive in Gaza on Sunday the Israeli
Defense Forces released this video which
they say shows a Hamas tunnel underneath
the alifa hospital this is an Israeli
military Jeep they brought into the
hospital and CCTV footage which they
claim shows hostages being taken into
the hospital on October 7th Global News
cannot yet verify this video The World
Health Organization says more than 200
patients and staff remain inside alifa I
absolutely humbled by the work of you
and your team the heroic efforts that
you've made this new footage shows wh
workers visiting the complex on Saturday
as hundreds of people fled a site who
staff has called a death zone they say
they saw a mass grave at its entrance
the who also says it is planning further
rescue missions to get alifa Patients
Out pending safety guarantees from
Israel and Hamas on Sunday a further 135
Canadians permanent residents and their
relatives were added to a list of those
approved to leave
Gaza Palestinian Canadian nabila Mana
arrived into Egypt saying she had to
leave some family behind in Gaza those
135 people with links to Canada are in
addition to the
376 that Global Affairs Canada said had
already left as of Friday Jeff redond
Shannon in London thanks red Israel's
military says Hamas is holding 239
hostages inside Gaza but negotiators are
reportedly close to a deal that would
see dozens of Women and Children
released it would also reportedly
involve a 5-day pause in the fighting as
Mike Armstrong reports while the deal
isn't done there is hope a breakthrough
could be
imminent even as hostilities continue on
the ground there are negotiations
between the two sides in this conflict
though not face Toof face talks between
Hamas and Israel are taking place in
Cotter through mediators qari officials
the US and at times Egypt have been
involved according to the qari Prime
Minister a deal for the release of some
hostages may be imminent the sticking
points honestly uh uh at this stage are
more uh practical
logistical the foundation of the
tentative agreement that would at least
temporarily stop the fighting seems to
be
settled according to reports it's a
six-page document some of the finer
details are still being ironed
out but the basics are that Hamas would
release 50 hostages women and children
being held in Gaza in return both sides
would pause fighting for 5 days and
Israel would allow more humanitarian Aid
in the Israeli ambassador to the US
Sunday morning on ABC said he's hope for
I don't want to go into the details of
these talks they are obviously very
sensitive the less we go into the
details the better the chances of such a
deal but they are very serious
efforts the Israeli Prime Minister said
as recently as Saturday that right now
there is no deal and that his government
won't Buckle under International
pressure calling for a
ceasefire but he is also under pressure
from here at home there have been
several rallies this weekend pushing
Benjamin Netanyahu to free the hostages
bring them home now
now it appears the two sides have been
close to a deal at a few points over the
last month but each time something got
in the way there are a lot of things to
figure out such as how the hostages
would be handed over and the assurances
Hamas Fighters transporting them would
be allowed to leave safely whatever
happens Benjamin Netanyahu says a pause
would be temporary Israeli troops as
soon as it expired would go right back
to rooting out Hamas Fighters Jeff m
Armstrong in Jerusalem thanks Mike a
28-year-old Toronto man is facing
multiple charges in connection to three
separate hate motivated assaults
targeting members of the Muslim
Community in the most recent police
alleged Chandler Marshall attacked
worshippers outside a mosque Saturday
morning with rocks and a bike chain the
National Council of Canadian Muslims
says the hate needs to stop we will not
be
intimidated while our first priority is
to ensure the safety of
worshippers we need to see long-term
change to fight all forms of hate
including
islamophobia Marshall is also accused of
two assaults early Wednesday police
alleg she asked a cab driver if he was
Muslim then sprayed him in the face with
an unknown substance just a few hours
later he also allegedly sprayed a woman
who was wearing a hijab and said
derogatory racist
comments among those calling for an end
to the violence is a Jewish mother in BC
For Whom the Hamas attack in Israel hit
close to home one of her relatives is
believed to be held hostage by Hamas and
a former colleague Vivien silver was
killed on October 7th despite all of
that she's calling for peace and a pause
neug Gara has her
story inside her BC home Randy
sommerfeld holds on dearly to memories
of a time she felt Hope For Peace the
Jewish mother of two spent years working
in Israel with a nonprofit called save a
child's heart helping Palestinian kids
in need of care 3,500 kids have have
come to Israel for their treatment and
gone back at the organization's Hospital
in Israel children from around the world
who can't be treated in their home
communities are provided open heart
surgeries and postop Care half of them
are from the West Bank and Gaza the
group also trains Palestinian doctors so
the patients can receive the care they
need after returning
home sommerfeld also worked with peace
activist Vivien silver killed in hamas's
October 7th attack when I met her she
actually gave me the advice cuz she I
was from Canada living in Israel she was
giving me the advice she's like make
local friends that are born and raised
here she also has a personal connection
her husband's 17-year-old cousin named
ofir a presumed hostage of Hamas
kidnapped from the home of his
girlfriend and her family the
family saw him being put into a black
car and driven across Gaza they shot the
family
dog they took the dad so his
girlfriend's dad and him and they left
the
girls ofir is among at least 200 people
including at least 30 teenagers and
children reported to be taken hostage by
Hamas I know people intimately on both
sides of this divide and and if we don't
remember to put humans first and
Humanity first and compassion
first before political agendas before
pointing fingers before all of this then
then we have nothing sommerfeld's
message is one of peace and pause in the
middle of so much polarization Nara
Global
News turning now to another conflict
Russia's war on Ukraine for the second
night in a row the Russian military
launched several waves of drone attacks
striking keev and surrounding regions
most were shot down and there were no
reports of any injuries two major Wars
in Ukraine and Gaza among other violent
conflicts are raising fears about the
potential for further escalation a new
opinion poll suggests people around the
world are worried about what comes next
Heidi petk has the
details pal the violence in the Middle
East brought out protesters with a
message to dignitaries attending the
hellofax International Security Forum
this weekend we're losing people we're
losing children and that's not okay
anywhere there's nothing Jewish about
violence so I'm here to call for a
ceasefire earlier inside a former prime
minister of Israel said the state cannot
stop until Hamas is defeated if Israel
government cannot survive cannot live up
to its very basic commitment to its
citizens if Hamas can control or come
back as a military power as Russia
continues its attack on Ukraine and
tensions in Asia persist there is
evidence people around the world are
fearful amidst it all a new poll
conducted on behalf of the Halifax
International Security Forum has found
that across 30 countries the majority of
people last Feel the world has become
more dangerous over the past year in
fact the ipsus poll found 84% feel that
way 70% said they expect a global
conflict similar to the world wars in
the next 25 years and 69% worry about
the potential of Chinese Le conflict in
Asia similar to Russia's attack on
Ukraine those figures slightly down from
last year although the poll was taken
before the Hamas attack on Israel the
public understands that it's a it's a
pretty messy dangerous place out there
and that we've gone through particularly
through the course of the pandemic a lot
of disruption disruption leads to other
disruption it should be a reason for all
of us to be engaged for this American
law and policy Professor the feeling of
insecurity should be met with action to
defend democracy both outside and within
home borders if we can't make sure that
we live in functioning democracies we're
not going to be of much use to anybody
else for many dealing with this time of
unrest has meant protests like this
Heidi petacha Global News
Halifax former first lady rosalin Carter
has died the Carter Center said in a
statement that she'd been living with
dementia and died peacefully at home
with her family by her side rosin and
Jimmy Carter were married for more than
77 years and rosin was considered
Jimmy's closest adviser during his
presidency and the Decades of
humanitarian work that followed rosn
Carter was
96 tragedy strikes this year's biggest
Music Tour coming up the death of a
Brazilian fan at a Taylor Swift concert
Sparks scrutiny
welcome back Taylor Swift postponed her
concert in Brazil this weekend after a
fan who attended an earlier performance
on Friday collapsed and later died the
23-year-old's death is now under
investigation but is already sparking
calls for stronger safety measures for
fans Friday's concert in Rio was held in
scorching sauna-like conditions but
attendees were not allowed to bring
bottles of water into the open air
station Stadium Mike dret has the latest
fans lined up for hours before Taylor
Swift's concert in Rio de Janeiro on
Friday the temperature outside was 39° C
humidity making it feel much warmer one
woman who attended the show said nton
Santos Olympic Stadium felt like a sauna
23-year-old anac Clara Benavides Machado
died in hospital after being treated by
paramedics at the show according to the
tour's organizer in Brazil the office of
Rio's public prosecutor says a criminal
investigation is underway though the
cause of death has not been confirmed
the heat is a prime suspect people
attending the concert weren't permitted
to bring water bottles into the stadium
there were water stations inside but
some said they were difficult to access
and Swift stopped her show at one point
to ask staff to bring water to a group
of fans who caught her
attention with the country in the midst
of a prolonged spring Heat Wave
politicians in Brazil say water bottles
must be allowed along with free and
accessible drinking water temperatures
hit 58° last week Swift isn't the first
performer to deal with unsafe
temperatures last August more than a
dozen people at a Snoop Dog concert in
Houston were taken to hospital for heat
related illness the month before 17 of
Ed Sheeran's fans at his Pittsburgh
concert wound up in hospital and country
singer Jason alen had to end his
Connecticut show early struggling to
perform in the extreme heat doctors say
heat shouldn't be underestimated early
warning signs include nausea headache
and dizziness and can escalate to heat
exhaustion or heat stroke Mike drle
Global News
Toronto an Arab activist's call for
compassion in Israel still ahead how the
crisis made her uphill battle even
[Music]
steeper welcome back an Arab activist in
Israel says she's caught in the middle
of an impossible plight omna canana has
dedicated years to uniting women from
different backgrounds fostering peace
and friendship but the conflict raging
in Gaza has upended both her work and
her world Crystal ganing
Reports here this is my own kitchen omna
canana says her kitchen is her domain
and like omna herself there's much more
than what you see at first glance throw
the
cupboard next door
[Music]
please I invite yeah I invite all the
women to sit here we used to discuss
many subject but I call this room social
University Muslims Jews Christians
everyone together sharing their culture
experiences and hopes we are women we
have big heart we can accept each other
we can listen to each other we can hung
each other
but things changed on October 7th when
Hamas Fighters entered Israel killing
more than 1,400 people and taking
hundreds hostage omna says she's lost
friends since that day many people in
her Arab Community she says are afraid
to go to work afraid to interact with
those outside of curari for fear they'll
be seen as the enemy when I say the T
they destroy Gaza also I am a sensitive
girl this is really relative my relative
this is my
religious I feel bad when I said they
kill the Jewish also this is my friend I
feel
bad to I can explain this feeling a
fracturing of a community she dedicated
herself to building after the war in
2014 omno was joined by many others for
a large Neighbors in peace roadside show
of solidarity attended by people of
different faiths sometime I need
somebody to Hung me and it's very
difficult the other side can't
understand you because uh it seems that
they are not really acquainted of your
culture R Masa lives in the same
Community as omna he says emotions are
too raw now but feels peaceful
coexistence is
possible even uh when I meet someone who
is very fanatic and would talk to me in
fanatic way I can understand him because
it doesn't come just from
somewhere he's been brought up by uh
this culture all I have to do is just
open the gates for New
Prospect if we feel equal if we feel
company if we feel peace we can live
together and this is my
flag a hope she holds with passion
Crystal ganing Global
News gray cup Glory up next the David
and Goliath battle at Canadian
football's biggest
[Music]
game the 110th gray cup is kicking off
tonight and this year's matchup sees two
teams meeting in the final for the first
time the Winnipeg Blue Bombers are
trying to cement themselves as a dynasty
will the Montreal aletes have been hot
after struggling earlier in the season
sha OA got the tough gig today he's in
Hamilton for us the host of this year's
CFL championship game
Sean Jeff like beaver tals and maple
syrup the gray cup is indisputably
Canadian and fans have come here to
Hamilton from all over the country to
celebrate the Canadian Football
Championship it's the Canadian sporting
event CFL fans plan ahead to attend
every year the gray C I bought my ticket
before winipeg was in it and you know
what it's it's a lot of fun look at all
the fans people the color smaller teams
it's like a it's like a Canadian thing
right many have spent most of the week
in Hamilton coming from all over the
country even if their teams aren't here
it matters not that your team is in the
great cup it matters that you support
the CFL we love the gr cup we love the
gr
cup the city shut down several blocks of
the downtown core this week so football
fans could come together many fans say
there's no better Canadian game or
supporters everybody from all around the
country coming together and you don't
know each other but this weekend
everyone's family the CFL claims this
year was one of its most successful in
part because of fan support it's really
good for the league it's really good
overall for everybody a year ago the
Montreal Alouettes had no owner now as
they arrived at the stadium to prepare
for the game they have a chance to win
their first championship since 2010
we're on a mission Winnipeg making its
fourth appearance since 2019 when it
ended a long CFL DFT rout Testament to
the work that you put in the two teams
meeting for the first time in the gray
cup the underdog alett versus the Blue
Bombers who lost last year's Cup by just
one point three out of four years if we
were Cup champions that absolutely is a
dynasty it cements the dynasty for Coach
OE for a number of the players that have
stuck around the alets got here by
defeating the Toronto Argonauts in the
Eastern final convincingly the Argonauts
had the best record in the CFL this year
still the blue bers are the favorite and
if they win the gray Cup today it would
put them into the history books Jeff
Shan OA in Hamilton Ontario thanks Sean
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm Jeff simple tonight's
your Canada is Roos blanch New Finland
and Labrador